so first I wanted to know what is it
like going from the weekend to this with
Stella you have that experience of
working with her but what did she do for
you as an actor's director on set on
this that you didn't even know she was
capable of
well one having that sort of like
working relationship was really cool
because a lot of you know being on set
is having that short-term dialogue with
a director yeah I mean honestly there
was a lot of elements that were kind of
the saying what I love about Stella is
she's very clear she has clarity she
knows what she wants and she knows how
to execute that and if you're not
executing that on the level of that she
thinks it's appropriate then you know
continue but you always know so that was
that was cool and I was pretty
consistent on the photograph too for
both of you what was a scene where you
and Stella need needed the most
collaboration to kind of find the scene
in the moment rather than finding it on
the page first um for me it was probably
Christina's bus-stop scene when she
leaves New Orleans for the last time
it's just a really heavy scene it
requires a lot of emotional death and
does me and Stella were able to
collaborate and bring that to life I
thought that that was one of the most
difficult things but then I really sat
and thought about it and this is why I'm
not an actor but even the very opening
the opening scene at the movie your
first scene where it's just you and a
camera we find more difficult and
emotional moment with with some co-stars
with you or a moment that's pretty much
all on your shoulders like that hmm
third I'd say they're about the same I
mean they both require a lot of work and
dedication and focus but that scene is
another really great example of the time
man
Stella we're really collaborating to
make that come to life so now this movie
is largely about a photograph that has a
lot of meaning and a lot of history to
it but nowadays with our phones we can
have thousands of photos
for you too I am curious what is the
thing you have the most photos of on
your phone is it a selfie as if food as
a family pets anything minor screenshots
yeah yeah I don't take a lot of pictures
of myself or like the things around me I
try to stay present
so yeah screenshots my names and stuff
yeah like me yeah or tweet yeah I
recently just got a puppy so it's a lot
of pictures of a 8 week old puppy it's
like a puppy it's a chihuahua all right
which I can go into but I won't but oh
yeah so it's a lot of that anyway she
said just like a lot of screenshots of
funny clips and stuff like that okay ask
one more question now what's the puppy's
name Azula yeah named her after 20 more
see characters one more photograph
question for you guys do you have a most
important photograph something that's
kind of ingrained in your mind and
connected to a memory or you know an
older photo that brings you back to your
history anything like that it's a
picture of myself and my mother when I
was like young dad I think just connects
me back to that dad unconditional love
which is his true love I've ever
experiences dev team especially at that
age like just knowing that she'd do
anything for me this one picture that I
have in mind of her but me it's just a
picture of my mother when she was in her
30s and she hates the photo because it
was an off guard but I think it was the
most beautiful photo she's ever taken
and I use it as a bookmark for every
book I read so I always keep it with me